a Russian break into the Southwest
Valley has business owners on alert
that's right well the punch not only
setting them back financially but also a
major concern of the crime happening
again
somebody broke the glass and then in the
middle night Mateo becera is still upset
about the surprise he came across last
week the door to his Southwest business
smashed
in one minute they broke the door the
glass they get in but they they nothing
to do you know they cannot they don't
take nothing a few feet away the door to
the neighboring restaurant also smashed
the morning of August 29th when Becerra
reported the crime to Metro Police he
says officers told him they were also
investigating other similar cases in the
area do you feel safe
I'm a little nervous actually business
owners in the shopping center off Fort
Apache and Tropicana are worried about
the culprit returning to the scene even
with security cameras in place they say
more needs to be done we get to see what
exactly this person do you know but then
our security system is inside not
outside right so and then that doesn't
prevent anybody to break in and take
anything repairing the damage will be
expensive Becerra says but serves as a
reminder for the entire staff that
safety is priority we talk with all
employees did somebody getting asked for
the money for something
taking me
in my life
well Metro Police tell us they are
investigating 17 incidents since August
26th I'll link to several suspects
wearing black hoodie sweatshirts and
blue or black pants now the suspects
have used three different Vehicles
during the crime